zdf heute live herzlich willkommen josua
kimmig einer der beliebtesten und
bekanntesten deutschen fußballspieler
möchte sich erstmal nicht gegen korona
impfen lassen das sorgt für
gesprächsstoff wir reden auch darüber
heute abend schauen uns aber erstmal an
womit er seine entscheidung begründet
und wie die bundesregierung heute darauf
reagiert hat
es geht einfach darum dass ich noch ein
paar bedenken habe deswegen ist es auch
sehr gut möglich dass ich mich in
zukunft impfen lasse es gibt auf diese
fragen klare und überzeugende antworten
zur nationalen und internationalen
experten und so dass ich eigentlich nur
sagen kann ich hoffe dass ich diese
informationen alle noch mal auf sich
wirken lässt und so stand auch
vielleicht für die impfung entscheidend
an denn als einer auf den millionen
schauen erklärt dann erst recht
vorbildwirkung von der zahl der
geimpften hängt ist eben ganz
entscheidend auch davon ab wie wir hier
in deutschland unser zusammenleben in
der pandemie organisieren können
tja und um welche bedenken es josua
kimmig und vielen anderen heute gegangen
ist und in den letzten tagen gegangen
ist sie zu dieser entscheidung geführt
haben darüber sprechen wir gleich in der
sendung wir schauen mal kurz auf den
instagram account von josua kimmig da
sehen wir seinen letzten pos der bezieht
sich auf das 4 0 gegen hoffenheim und
darunter sind über 4000 kommentare und
wir sehen hier ist viel zuspruch viel
support für ihn für das was er gesagt
hat für die bedenken die er geäußert hat
aber es gibt auch viel kritik zb
unterstützung gibt es von heike 5 966
super interview gestern chapeau ich bin
selbst geimpft und unterstütze deine
einstellung darauf gibt es viele
verschiedene antworten waren wir mal so
ein bisschen durch
wie gesagt viel kritik viel zuspruch von
allem ein bisschen dabei einer schreibt
ein user namens daniel richard ich sehe
das genauso wie du ich bin selber
geimpft würde aber nie jemanden
verurteilen wenn er das noch nicht will
ich denke wenn man kimmig die sachlage
genauer erklären würde mit fakten dann
würde er sich auch irgendwann impfen
lassen und wenn nicht dann muss man das
auch akzeptieren ich bin sehr gespannt
freue mich auf ihre und eure meinungen
und kommentare und freue mich besonders
um genau das zu tun nämlich die sachlage
besser zu erklären bei uns heute abend
in der sendung jemanden begrüßen zu
können der sich damit auskennt wir haben
nämlich in der sendung professor eva
hungers sie ist mitglied der ständigen
impfkommission und direktorin des
instituts für allgemeinmedizin der
universitätsmedizin göttingen
schönen guten abend frau professor
hungers
wenn ihr fragen nach sie fragen an frau
professor thomas haben dann wie immer in
die kommentare oder wenn er oder sie die
zdf heute.de die zdf- heute- app nutzen
heute live gibt es leider noch nicht
aber man könnte sie erfinden dann bitte
per e mail an die zdf heute - live at
zdf.de frau professor thomas was josua
kimmig an bedenken geäußert hat geht vor
allem in richtung der langzeitfolgen er
befürchtet langzeitfolgen einer corona
impfung was können sie da antworten
antworten entschuldigung
kann antworten das nach allem ja
biologischen wissen wissen über
impfstoffe was ist bis heute gibt und
zwar über alle gebräuchlichen impfstoffe
ist noch nie spät aufgetretener
nebenwirkungen gegeben hat
nebenwirkungen von impfstoffen treten
relativ schnell nach der impfung aus
innerhalb weniger tage oder wochen und
wenn es die gäbe bei den zugelassenen
impfstoffen oder die die es gibt die
kennen wir bereits es ist ja noch nie in
der geschichte der menschheit sind so
viele menschen quasi gleichzeitig und so
gut beobachtet gegen irgendetwas geimpft
worden was es vorher manchmal gab ist
dass nebenwirkungen die zwar früh
aufgetreten sind erst spät gefunden
worden
wenn nämlich nicht so viele menschen
gleichzeitig geimpft werden dann kann es
lange dauern bis dann war jemand mit
einer nebenwirkung eine nebenwirkung hat
und bis das dann dem impfstoff
zugeordnet werden kann da sind wir aber
im moment in einer situation die
eigentlich maximale sicherheit bietet
hier schreibt ein user namens dj über
youtube ich zitiere ich checke das
argument mit den langzeitfolgen nicht
nach sechs monaten gibt es was oder
nicht danach etwas zu bekommen was davon
herrühren soll ist extremst
unwahrscheinlich also lasst euch einfach
impfen klare botschaft können sie darauf
eingehen was mit diesen sechs monaten
gemeint ist
ja wie der schreiber jetzt auf die sechs
monate kommt weiß ich nicht auch so
lange dauert es normalerweise nicht die
nebenwirkungen der impfstoffe die es
hier in deutschland gibt sind treten
alle innerhalb von tagen bzw von wenigen
wochen auf und sind im prinzip innerhalb
von vier wochen gefunden und
identifiziert und zugeordnet worden
nachdem diese impfstoffe in der breiten
anwendung waren selbst die
nebenwirkungen die so selten sind dass
sie in den impfstoff studien mit etwa
30.000 personen noch nicht auftraten
oder nur so vereinzelt ja als einzelfall
von daher braucht man auch keine sechs
monate dafür das geht noch schneller
es gibt viele fragen zu nebenwirkungen
und die beziehen sich aber auch darauf
was für eine art von impfstoff verimpft
wurde und bevor wir da in die tiefe
gehen fast pablo selami zusammen welche
verschiedenen corona impfstoffe es denn
derzeit überhaupt gibt
in deutschland sind bisher zwei
impfstoff typen zugelassen zum einen der
so genannte vektorbasierte impfstoff und
der m rna dem stoff sektor impfstoffe
bestehen aus für den menschen harmlosen
viren den sogenannten vektoren
ausgestattet mit dem genetischen bauplan
des corona virus nach der impfung gibt
das vector virus die informationen an
die menschlichen zellen ab dank dieses
eingeschleusten bauplans kann die zelle
teile des corona virus nachbauen und das
immunsystem kann dagegen antikörper
bilden beispiel hierfür ist der
impfstoff des britisch schwedischen
herstellers astrazeneca
außerdem gibt es die sogenannten m rna
impfstoffe hierbei werden
erbinformationen aus dem virus entnommen
diese dient als eine art bauplan nachdem
der körper selbst ungefährliche virus
proteine herstellt und gegen die bildet
der körper dann abwehrstoffe beispiel
hierfür der impfstoff von biotech pfizer
die sogenannten tod impfstoffe in
deutschland noch nicht zugelassen
enthalten abgetötete krankheitserreger
die erkennt der körper als fremdkörper
das abwehrsystem wird angeregt
antikörper dagegen zu produzieren ohne
dass die krankheit tatsächlich ausbricht
entwickelt wird ein solcher tod
impfstoff derzeit vom französischen
unternehmen weil nie war
der frau professor thomas ist heißt das
josua kimmig auf einen solchen tod
impfstoff wartet weil er sagt die haben
sich in der vergangenheit bewährt und
bevor ich was ausprobieren was jetzt
ganz neu ist möchte ich lieber einen
solchen mir von der struktur her
bekannten tot impfstoff und das ist
nicht nur eine meinung die er hat
sondern die hört man auch öfter von
anderen was können sie dazu sagen
muss das mal einleiten dazu sagen dass
alle impfstoffe die es auf der welt und
erst recht die es in europa gegen kuwait
19 gibt keine lebend impfstoffe sind
sondern tod impfstoffe von daher war
auch die erklärung der beiden
impfstoff typen vorhin ja für alle beide
ein bisschen irreführend
das ist so dass
gehen sie sehr gerne in die tiefe
deshalb haben wir mit unserer haben wir
sie in unsere sendung geholt damit sie
licht ins dunkel bringen können und das
auch noch ein bisschen genauer
definieren können bitte nehmen sie sich
die zeit
die erklärung der grundprinzipien war
richtig die vector impfstoffe enthalten
erkältungsviren vom affen die aber auch
teil inaktiviert sind die sich also
nicht mehr vermehren können in dem sinne
auch nicht lebendig sind und die
enthalten nicht den bauplan des corona
virus sondern nur den bauplan für ein
winziges stück des corona virus das
sogenannte spike protein und der ist das
stückchen ja das eiweiß des corona virus
gegen das alle impfstoffe sich richten
alle
sind vor allen dingen gegen das protein
gerichtet und auch diese leben
impfstoffe sind keine lebend impfstoffe
und die m rna impfstoffe enthalten
ebenfalls amerika also einen bauplan der
aber nicht im corona virus entnommen ist
sondern der synthetisch hergestellt sind
sie sind vollständig künstlich
hergestellt da ist überhaupt kein virus
drin und auch das ist nur dass bauplan
stück für das protein und in bei beiden
ist es selbstverständlich so dass da
überhaupt keine krankheit ausbricht
sondern das eben nur ein teil des corona
virus nachgebaut werden soll damit der
körper dadurch antikörper bilden kann
und in beiden fällen baut dieses spike
protein der eigene körper
anders als bei den impfstoffen die eben
aus einem inaktivierten ganzen virus
bestehen da wird es von außen zugeführt
sozusagen und sodann soll der körper
dagegen antikörper erkennen das heißt
also ganz also keine komplett neuen
prinzipien okay aber das heißt ganz doof
gefragt er war keiner dieser impfstoffe
macht etwas in meinem körper dass sich
dann für immer verändert außer für eine
hoffentlich sehr lang anhaltende
immunität gegen dieses virus aber es
macht nichts in meinem körper was mir
auf dauer schaden könnte
nein machen sie nicht sie soll natürlich
was auf die dauer machen nämlich ihnen
antikörper gegen das
corona virus verschaffen und in ihrem
körper das gedächtnis oder immun
gedächtnis ihres körpers verankern dass
coronaviren feinde sind die man schnell
abwehren muss das ist ja das wirkprinzip
eines jeden impfstoffs auch bei denen
gegen andere krankheiten aber nein sie
verändern nicht die gene und sie
provozieren auch keine infektion
irgendeiner art weder mit dem corona wir
uns noch mit dem vector virus also es
bleibt nichts zurück sozusagen außer der
hoffentlich dann bestehenden
immunisierung
es bleibt die immunität zu rücken und in
ihrem gedächtniszellen
ja die kenntnis dass coronaviren
abgewehrt werden müssen und wie das geht
wie man also antikörper gegen speck
protein baut aber man wird dadurch zum
ersten ist ja das prinzip eines jeden
impfstoffs man wird dadurch zum beispiel
nicht unfruchtbar wie man ja auch immer
wieder von skeptikern oder impfgegnern
hört
nein auf gar keinen fall
das war von vorneherein ein jahr ein
irrtum oder ein missverständnis diese
annahme das ist inzwischen ja sowohl von
der
biologischen grundlage und erklärung
ganz klar widerlegt als auch dadurch
widerlegt das ja frauen nach corona
impfung schwanger geworden sind gesunde
kinder bekommen haben in den impfstoff
studien genauso häufig die schwanger
geworden sind die
den impfstoff bekommen haben wie die die
placebo bekommen haben und das ist
inzwischen ja auch weltweit viele viele
frauen gibt die kogit 19 also die
erkrankung überlebt haben also viel
speck protein vom virus hergestellt im
körper hatten und die auch schwanger
geworden sind und gesunde kinder
bekommen haben was braucht man nicht zu
befürchten die sich für männer genauso
also auch männer werden nicht
unfruchtbar reinhard goebel fragt per e
mail werden nicht unfruchtbar reinhard
goebel fragt per e mail noch mal in
richtung em stoffe sie haben es gerade
schon angesprochen aber vielleicht
können sie es noch einmal vertiefen er
schreibt wir hatten doch noch nie mrn
abstimmt amr n a impfstoffe wie können
wir danach so kurzer zeit schon davon
reden das langzeit nebenwirkungen nicht
auftreten
wir hatten einen fast fertigen m rna
impfstoff der dann nicht mehr zugelassen
worden ist nämlich gegen die erste
corona gegen die ersten beiden corona
virus
epidemien die dann aber in europa nicht
mehr so angekommen sind saß und märz
damit ist der impfstoff dann nicht mehr
breit zugelassen worden und das prinzip
m rna zu verwenden um immunität zu
erzeugen das wurde von der firma
bajonett ja auch schon vorher eingesetzt
gegen krebserkrankungen
das hat dort wo nicht die breite
anwendung weil das nicht so viele
menschen betrifft also von daher ist es
ein prinzip was zwar als impfstoff jetzt
zum ersten mal in der breiten anwendung
ist aber nicht erst von jetzt auf gleich
erfunden wurde und ja wie eingangs schon
gesagt es ist unbekannt und wäre auch in
keiner weise erklärbar dass impfstoffe
ja erst nach sehr langer zeit dann
plötzlich eine schad wirkung entfalten
ein kommentar von matt g impfen kann
nebenwirkungen haben schreibt er über
youtube aber eine infektion mit dem
corona virus ist schlimmer also auch ein
klares statement für das impfen eine
frage von curious bei 90 ich möchte
wissen ob die impfung das immunsystem an
sich verändert gegenüber anderen viren
oder bakterien
ich bin jemand der so gut wie nie krank
wird und möchte das nicht aufs spiel
setzen
ist eine schwierig zu beantwortende
frage es scheint ja so zu sein dass der
der fragen die hier der autor dieser
frage ein sonst gut funktionierendes
immunsystem hat was schon gegen sehr
viele andere krankheitserreger parallel
eine ordentliche abwehr bereitstellt und
es gibt jetzt überhaupt keinen grund
anzunehmen dass
antikörper gegen korona viren egal ob
sie jetzt auf dem weg einer natürlichen
infektion mit all den damit verbundenen
gefahren erworben wurden oder eben durch
eine impfung dem schaden sollten
manchmal ist es so dass impfungen das
immunsystem insgesamt auch über das
eigentliche virus hinaus
anregen sag ich jetzt mal das ist aber
im allgemeinen eher von vorteil
also ich hätte auch da keine bedenken
und zum kommentar vorher wir wissen auch
noch nicht was das saas koch 2 virus für
langzeit folgen hat das ist nämlich auch
noch nicht so lange bekannt nur etwa ein
gutes halbes jahr länger als der
impfstoff und von daher überwiegt
weiterhin sicherlich die gefahr einer
infektion
die gefahr der impfung mit diesem
winzigen teil stückchen was nicht
vernehmungsfähig ist
ein großes thema das viele umtreibt und
was sie als ständige info impfkommission
ja auch derzeit beschäftigt ist die
frage nach kinderimpfungen es sind eher
im moment
zulassungsverfahren im gange um kinder
unter zwölf auch impfen zu können
wie
schätzen sie das ein
viele eltern sind skeptisch was die
kinder impfungen angeht gibt es da
ängste die sie vielleicht nehmen können
die impfung von jüngeren kindern ist
etwas was die ständige impfkommission
dann genau betrachten muss und wird wenn
ja wir nähere informationen dazu haben
wenn also ausreichend daten zur impfung
von kindern und zur sicherheit dieser
impfstoffe vorliegen und dann werden wir
das betrachten und entsprechende
modellrechnungen vornehmen und dann
eine empfehlung dazu aussprechen oder
eben auch nicht es war ja auch bei der
empfehlung zur impfung jugendliche über
zwölf so dass wir das erst sehr
sorgfältig betrachtet und analysiert
haben und im übrigen auch darauf
gewartet haben in einem sommer in dem
hier instanzen extrem niedrig waren also
nicht viel passieren konnte dass daten
aus anderen ländern vorlagen um eben die
sicherheitsdaten zur impfung von
jugendlichen zu haben das wird bei den
jüngeren kindern nicht anders sein denn
auch dort ist es so dass die ja extrem
selten bis nie schwere verläufe haben
dass also die kogit erkrankung bei
kindern
längst keine so schwere erkrankung ist
wie bei erwachsenen
und somit muss der impfstoff sehr sicher
sein und die zeit und die informationen
um das zu beurteilen wird die ständige
impfkommission sich sicherlich nehmen
frau professor thomas ich möchte sie zum
ende unseres gesprächs nicht dazu
treiben hand chemische entscheidungen
oder äußerungen zu kommentieren aber wir
sehen unabhängig davon dass die zahlen
weiter steigen
dass der herbst kommt dass man nicht
genau weiß was da auf uns zukommt wie
wichtig ist es aus ihrer sicht auch aus
sicht der stiko dass sich jetzt die
menschen impfen lassen die noch nicht
geimpft sind mit hinblick auf den winter
im hinblick auf den persönlichen schutz
dieser menschen und auch im hinblick auf
den verlauf der pandemie für die
allgemeinheit wäre das extrem wichtig
weil einfach erwachsene die nicht
geimpft sind selber gefährdet sind je
mehr desto älter sie sind und je mehr
desto mehr vorerkrankungen sie haben und
da ist die impfung einfach der beste und
wirksamste und vernünftigste schutz und
wenn es gelingt die zahlen in der
gesamten bevölkerung niedrig zu halten
oder auch wieder abzusenken sie steigen
ja im moment schon dann sind halt auch
die besser geschützt bei denen die
impfung entweder nicht so gut wirkt weil
das immunsystem eben alt ist oder
vielleicht aus krankheitsgründen nicht
so
tatkräftig nicht so stark ist und eben
auch die jüngeren kinder sind dann ja
durch eine geimpfte umgebung deutlich
besser geschützt von daher kann ich nur
alle ermuntern und ermutigen sich impfen
zu lassen das ist ganz klar die bessere
wahl im vergleich zu einer inflation für
alle erwachsenen und die impfstoffe sind
sicher
sagt professor eva hamas mitglied der
ständigen impfkommission vielen dank für
dieses gespräch und die beantwortung der
vielen verschiedenen fragen heute abend
danke frau professor hungers ja ich habe
es gerade gesagt die zahlen steigen das
robert koch institut meldet heute sechs
1573 neuinfektionen das sind
2517 mehr als am montag vor einer woche
und damit steigt auch die sieben tage
incident auf von 106,3 auf jetzt
110,1 zahlen die sicherlich auch ihn
beunruhigen der jetzt bei uns in der
sendung ist und auch schon öfter bei uns
war professor thorsten lehrer professor
für klinische pharmazie an der
universität des saarlandes in
saarbrücken herr professor lehr ich
grüße sie diese zahlen wie groß ist ihre
sorge dass dieser winter ein
ungemütlicher werden wird
ja also momentan stehen alle zahlen und
zeichen nicht darauf dass sich irgendein
spannungs lage abzeichnet sondern eher
das gegenteil ist endlich der fall ich
denke wir sehen gerade in den anstieg in
den herbst und den winter ein der uns
noch sehr stark beschäftigen dürfte mit
dem was noch kommen wird
sie sind eher eine von denen die
versuchen zu berechnen was noch kommen
wird sie pflegen
das computermodell kowitz simulator mit
alle zwei wochen mit den neuesten daten
und versuchen das erwartete
infektionsgeschehen vorherzusagen und
sie haben uns für diese sendung
verschiedene grafiken mitgebracht wir
fangen mal mit einer an in der sie die
inzidenz entwicklung für die kommenden
wochen voraus berechnet haben vielleicht
können wir die uns jetzt gemeinsam
angucken da sieht man die zahlen wie sie
sich entwickeln würden wenn man einfach
so weitermachen würde wie bisher
ich weiß nicht ob sie es auch sehen
können noch mal vielleicht können sie
diese erste grafik
mal ein bisschen mit mit leben füllen
kerne gerne also was wir hier sehen sind
erstmal diese sieben tage sind sie denn
sie wird zu groß und zu gute kennen wir
sehen hier zwei kurven das blaue ist
letztendlich die kurve aus dem letzten
jahr 2020 und das rot rötlich braune ist
die kurve jetzt aus diesem jahr und was
man hier sieht es letztendlich die
entwicklung jetzt über die zeit hinweg
und wir sind jetzt ungefähr
ende oktober und das ist dann dort wo
dieser strahlen ein bisschen nach oben
geht das ist letztendlich ein szenario
was wir machen dann müssen wir ein
bisschen aufpassen dass wir jetzt nicht
sagen wir machen eine vorhersage sondern
wir simulieren ihren szenario von dem
was eintreten kann das ist natürlich
immer erst mal hier in dem fall auch
unter der bedingung dass ich an der
infektion erst mal nichts ändert am
infektionsgeschehen das heißt dass es so
bleibt wie es ist und dann würden wir
hier sehen dass die instanzen doch
relativ rasch ansteigen würden ungefähr
so steil wie es letztes jahr auch wie
was auch letztes jahr gesehen haben also
das heißt die geschwindigkeit des
anstiegs ist eigentlich nicht unbedingt
schneller als das das wir letztes jahr
gesehen haben nur wenn wir nichts machen
würden und das ist jetzt wieder so einen
präventionstag sind das erfahren wir
sagen jetzt passt auf leute wenn wir
nichts machen steigen die zahlen sehr
stark an dann würden die zahlen sehr
stark nach oben gehen ich gehe nicht
davon aus dass sie in diesem ausmaß sich
dann wirklich auch austoben werden
sondern in der regel dürfte es dann eine
intervention geben entweder wird die
regierung irgendwelche maßnahmen
ergreifen oder die bevölkerung zieht
sich entsprechend zurück also ich glaube
was wir hier sehen nach oben hinaus ist
eine art worst case szenario was nicht
eintreten wird aber die entwicklung in
der nächsten zeit dürfte sich erst mal
in den nächsten ein zwei drei wochen in
ähnlichem maße hier entwickeln und bei
der blauen kurve noch mal zur erinnerung
warum es dort abgeflachtes war letztlich
weil wir dann letztes jahr natürlich mit
der lok downlight ab november dann
natürlich schon erste maßnahmen
ergriffen haben die dann mitte dezember
mit dem haken lockdown dann auch stärke
wieder gegriffen haben deswegen sind
dort die zahlen dann nicht mehr stark
angestiegen das wort maßnahmen und
politische entscheidungen haben sie
gerade schon genannt wir schauen mal auf
die nächste grafik was nämlich passieren
würde wenn maßnahmen ergriffen würden
und da würde ich sie auch noch mal
bitten welche art von maßnahmen sie sich
denn da
voraus berechnet haben denn einen lock
down wie wir in das letzte jahr erlebt
haben den hoffen wir ja alle nicht mehr
zu erleben also wenn man sich anschaut
die nächste grafik wie sie sich
entwickelt wenn es beschränkungen
welcher art gebe was was sehen sie davor
jetzt sehe ich gerade das wäre ein
professor lehr verloren haben aber wir
haben ihn wieder und jetzt kann ich auch
nicht genau sehen ob das die erste
grafik genau das ist die nächste grafik
wir sehen hier die orangene kurve würde
erstmal weiter ansteigen bis zu einer
wie auch immer gearteten maßnahme die
aber dann hoffentlich in diesem jahr und
das ist ja auch im moment die politik
der stunde kein lockdown wäre wie wir
ihn im vergangenen jahr erleben mussten
ja richtig was wir hier jetzt sehen und
was wir hier jetzt angenommen haben für
dieses szenario ist jetzt was wir sagen
okay wir gehen davon aus dass die
kontakte sich wieder so um 15 bis 20
prozent in etwa wieder reduzieren werden
das können natürlich verschiedene
maßnahmen sein die zu seiner reduktion
führen das können auch letztendlich
verschärfte kontrollen seien vielleicht
möglicherweise und 2g system das ist
nicht unbedingt gesagt welche maßnahme
das sein wird was wichtig es ist dass
wir ein bisschen mehr letztendlich
wieder
restriktion einbauen im
infektionsgeschehen das könnten
beispielsweise auch wieder vermehrt das
tragen von masken seien wichtig wird
aber auf jeden fall sein und das soll
uns hier eigentlich die die simulation
auch zeigen dieses szenario dass hier
ein dass hier eine kehrtwende relativ
leicht möglich ist mit einer leichten
beschränkung also das system ist gerade
relativ instabil das heißt wir sind auch
so eine kippa wo soll er die vielleicht
in die eine als auch in die andere
richtung abdriften könnte mit relativ
wenigen maßnahmen können wir das system
her wieder sozusagen in den griff
kriegen was hier natürlich auch noch
wird das dass wir weiterhin noch impfen
wobei wir jetzt momentan davon ausgehen
dass die impfung also mit dieser
schnecken artigen geschwindigkeit wie
sie momentan vorher schon noch weiter
geht das heißt dass er hier passiert bei
uns bei den impfungen nur noch so viel
wie wir jetzt auch aus den daten
herauslesen jetzt einen zusätzlichen
frust ist nicht drin was man aber schon
dazusagen muss selbst wenn wir jetzt
verstärkt impfen würden jetzt sofort
wenn sich jetzt sofort alle impfen
würden würden wir auch ein teil dieses
anstiegs erstmal nicht verhindern können
weil bis wir die vollständige immunität
haben dauert es einfach mal vier bis
sechs wochen in etwa bis dann wirklich
auch ja die vollständige der
vollständige schutz da herrscht und bis
dahin sind wir dann schon hier im mitte
november wo wir jetzt hier schon sind
also impfen hilft impfung hilft jedem
einzelnen das ist ganz wichtig nur der
inzidenz können wir vielleicht nicht so
stark zu rechnen tragen wie wir es
brauchen aber auch auf ihren punkt
zurückzukommen ich glaube auch nicht
dass wir in diesem winter noch mal mit
einem lokal rechnen wir haben sehr viele
geimpfte ich denke wir werden halt eben
verschiedene maßnahmen ergreifen müssen
dass wir dann entsprechend vielleicht
die ungeimpften ja wie soll ich sagen
vielleicht mit etwas weniger rechten
ausstatten als die geimpften und dadurch
vielleicht entsprechenden schutz bieten
können nun können ja könnte man sagen
moment mal man kann doch dieses jahr
eigentlich gar nicht mit dem letzten
jahr vergleichen denn wir haben in
diesem jahr eben eine impfung das heißt
wir haben leute die wenn sie es denn
bekommen wesentlich schwächere verläufe
haben das heißt es kommen auch viel
weniger leute ins krankenhaus auch dazu
haben sie eine grafik vorbereitet
nämlich die hospitalisierung rate die ja
auch ein instrument für die politik
geworden ist um zu entscheiden
welche maßnahmen ergreifen wir als
nächstes und hier sehen wir die belegung
der intensivstationen
2020 und 2021 im vergleich wie
kommentieren sie das
ja genau also was wir hier sehen ist
jetzt das ist jetzt eben die belegung
der intensivstation wir sehen und das
haben wir den letzten zeit auch schon
gesehen hier natürlich ein anstieg jetzt
kann man natürlich sagen okay wir haben
die impfung das haben wir letztendlich
bei der incidents jetzt auch aber wir
dürfen nicht vergessen im vergleich zum
letzten jahr haben wir jetzt zwar nicht
nur die impfung sondern wir haben
natürlich auch eine etwas aggressivere
mutante am start mit der delta variante
haben wir eine variante die doppelt so
infektiös ist und natürlich auch schwere
verläufe bei den patientinnen und
patienten hervorruft also das heißt es
nutzt nichts allein das ich geimpft
werden sondern wir können auch
letztendlich bei den jüngeren jetzt
inzwischen dann schwere verläufe
erzeugen dass es letztendlich das was
passiert und dass wir hier auch sehen
weshalb auch jetzt die infektion schon
wieder die belegung auf den
intensivstationen entsprechend wieder
ansteigen das alter der belegung ist
letztendlich halt jünger wir sehen dass
die patientinnen und patienten jünger
werden im schnitt sind jetzt deutlich
jünger als im vergleich noch zum winter
aber sie haben trotzdem schwere verläufe
was prinzipiell aber auch noch passiert
und das dürfen wir auch nicht vergessen
dadurch dass die patientinnen und
patienten jünger sind haben sie
eigentlich eine bessere überlebenschance
das ist fantastisch aber wer überlebt
liegt und belegt letztendlich auch
länger die betten im krankenhaus und das
heißt die verbleiben letztendlich auch
länger das führt aber auch dazu dass die
betten letztendlich voller werden das
geht natürlich in so eine berechnung
auch mit ein im herbst und winter
letzten jahres sind natürlich sehr viele
ältere patientinnen und patienten dann
verstorben und die sind nach relativ
kurzer zeit auch schon verstorben wir
haben jetzt rein platzbelegung technisch
dann natürlich auch relativ schnell
wieder betten frei gemacht so dramatisch
und schrecklich das klingt so praktisch
war es dann letztendlich für die
belegung und das haben wir hier jetzt
nicht und wie gesagt wir haben einfach
auch schwere verläufe hier und was wir
hier sehen ist dass wir hier eigentlich
auch letztendlich ihnen vielleicht ein
möglicherweise ähnlichen anstieg
erwarten können wir das was wir auch im
letzten jahr dann entsprechend gesehen
haben obwohl halt wir hier nie etwas
einen etwas anderen verlauf haben aber
auch hier glaube ich wieder dass es hier
eine gewisse im intervention gibt und
dass wir hier natürlich
sicherlich auch eben durch impfungen
schon nochmal schützen können vielleicht
nicht sofort aber jeder einzelne sollte
sich jetzt für den lang entsprechend
schützen
hier hat interventionen gefallen genau
dass die passende grafik dazu denn das
würde passieren wenn man zum beispiel
auf zweig umsteigt oder wenn man ja die
masken pflicht wieder erweitert genau
richtig also und dass das zeigt uns
eigentlich dass wir hier wahrscheinlich
schon auch mal anstiege erwarten könnten
die auch gar nicht so gering sind also
das heißt dass wir noch mal ungefähr
eine knappe verdopplung der
belegungszahlen möglicherweise erreichen
können wenn wir hier sagen ich meine
mitte mitte november letztendlich wieder
verstärkt auch eingreifen etwas
versteckte eintreffen würden auch hier
sehen wir einfach das system ist relativ
labil ist kann ich mir eine wie die
andere richtung kippen und wir dürfen
einfach auch bei den krankenhäusern
moment nicht vergesst nicht
intensivstationen dass dort der anteil
momentan an non profit patient also
patientinnen und patienten die keine
kurve der kranken haben und auf
intensivstationen liegen relativ hoch
ist also der ist jetzt im herbst schon
so hoch wie normalerweise zu dem februar
des jahres ist das heißt wir haben wir
relativ viel belegung das heißt dort ist
zwar rechnerisch haben wir vielleicht
nicht so viel cobit patient wie letztes
jahr aber voll ist es auf den
intensivstationen trotzdem und die
letztendlich die pflegerinnen und
pfleger und das personal letztendlich
hat auch relativ ausgedünnt also die
situation ist nicht so rosig wie es
vielleicht auf diesen grafiken erscheint
und von daher sollten wir
dementsprechend auch vorbeugen
jetzt sind hier noch zwei fragen die ich
ihnen gerne hinten raus gebündelt
stellen würde wobei sie eine glaube ich
schon beantwortet haben nämlich mit der
sehr viel ansteckenden variante aber
christoph fahrrad fragt per e mail wieso
ist der anstieg der inzidenz im jahr
2021 trotz impfung höher als 2020 dass
die eine frage und die andere ist serena
pickerl fragt über facebook wenn so
viele menschen geimpft sind wieso sollen
dann die zahlen so weit nach oben gehen
werden die impf durchbrüche mitgezählt
genau also vielleicht machen wir erst
einmal den anstieg der inzidenz das ist
letztendlich sie haben schon gesagt das
liegt natürlich auch an der variante das
liegt daran dass wir diese delta
variante haben die jetzt auch ungefähr
doppelt so ansteckend ist also versuche
ich noch ganz zurück erinnern es gibt
diesen erwerb er sagt den letztendlich
aus wie viele nicht infizierter
infizierter ansteckt das war beim
wildtyp lag der so zwischen 2,7 und drei
ungefähr und jetzt bei der delta
variante liegt ungefähr bei 6 ist ein
infizierter kann im schnitt zumindest
doppelt so viele anstecken wenn sie
jetzt einfach bedenken dass sie jetzt
ungefähr zwar zwei drittel geimpft haben
dann sagen wir mal ganz grob über den
daumen gepeilt das ist die hälfte dann
der nivelliert sich das relativ stark
wieder raus also das heißt sie rechnen
schon ein bisschen den imperfekt einfach
durch die höhere infektiosität raus das
ist jetzt ein bisschen vereinfacht
dargestellt aber das erklärt zum einen
warum wir uns trotzdem noch stark
anstecken und wir haben natürlich
trotzdem auch noch den punkt dass die
geimpften natürlich trotzdem auch
infiziert werden können also auch hier
bei einer hohen infektionsrate haben wir
dann natürlich auch die geimpften die
dann infiziert werden können die diese
sogenannte nimmt durchbrüche haben und
die zählen wir natürlich auch mit bei
unserer berechnung die haben deutlich
milderen verlauf sie haben kein komplett
jahr folgen folgenlosen verlauf aber sie
sind deutlich reduzierte auch bei uns
unseren berechnungen und die gehen jetzt
endlich auch mit ein aber sie sehen
natürlich auch dass und das ist
natürlich zu was das nennt sich bedingte
wahrscheinlichkeit dass natürlich dann
wenn die die bedingung ist dass sie
relativ viele geimpfte haben dass ich
dann natürlich auch viele von den
geimpften infizieren werden das ist
einfach ja eben ein gesetz der
wahrscheinlichkeit und das was wir da
sehen dass endlich relativ normal und
das was wir gerade eben auch erwarten
und das vor allem halt viele impf
durchbrüche auch bei den älteren
patienten patienten erfolgen liegt halt
daran dass wir dort auch eben sehr viele
haben sich schon geimpft sind also das
heißt was wir da sehen ist im moment
nicht oder erwartet wie berechnen dass
letztendlich mit ein aber wie gesagt die
variante ist einfach aggressiver kann
man sagen sie ist infektiöser und damit
eben auch über den schweren verlauf
führt sie dann eigentlich zu einem
relativ ähnlichen ergebnis wie fast ohne
impfung aber wir dürfen nicht vergessen
die impfung wirkt trotzdem ohne diese
impfung wäre die situation um ein
vielfaches desaströser das dürfen wir
einfach nicht vergessen und sie schützen
natürlich jeden einzelnen von uns und
das müssen wir uns halt immer wieder
überlegen wir schützen uns selbst und
das was wir gerade auch schon gehört
haben was ganz wichtig ist wir schützen
damit auch die anderen das heißt also
auch damit dass wir die impfung schützen
wir natürlich unsere bevölkerung und
unsere liebsten unsere kinder schützen
auch dadurch das wie eine art puffer
einbauen und das ist natürlich ganz
wichtig finde ich auch für die jungen
eltern mit kindern die noch nicht gehen
werden können dass sie sich durch die
impfung auch nicht nur sich schützen
sondern eben auch ihre kinder oder wie
es ein user hier gerade bei youtube
geschrieben hat impfen stadt schimpfen
vielen dank professor lehr nach
saarbrücken für diese sehr erhellenden
grafiken und zahlen und danke dass sie
bei uns in der sendung waren und ihnen
zu hause vielen dank fürs mitmachen und
fragen und bis zum nächsten mal und
einen schönen abend